[Music]
[Applause]
albert breer's been all over this story
he's also traveling uh the country going
to nfl training camps which we'll get to
the nfl has three days to appeal what do
you think is happening right now and
will happen by 9 a.m on thursday morning
albert
i think there are a lot of league
officials that are probably on twitter
right now um
like just sort of taken the temperature
for
what the public reaction to all this is
because i don't think that that is
i think that's a very relevant piece of
the whole thing so
um how's the public reacting i think
that's that's a piece of it you know of
course i think they're going through
their own
um options here and really to me there
are three options to number one
you can pin this on sue robinson if
you're them and you can say we
negotiated this process two years ago
with the union we respect the process we
don't agree with her
view of the facts
but the process was a good one and we'll
stand by what she said
the second option would be you go to 8
or 10 or 12 games
and you say
now this is our decision to do this
we believe there's a little bit more um
there than sue robinson
thought
and if they do that then it becomes
their decision and then the question is
is that enough like does the public look
at an 8 or 10 or 12 game suspension is
enough and then maybe because deshawn
watson wants closure
he accepts it the third option is the
nuclear option which is you say
we're going to do what we want to do all
along we're going to give them a year
and then you wind up in court i i think
so
and if you wind up in court that's the
other part of this dam that's really
interesting is
if you wind up in court that could mean
deshaun watson plays in the opener
because at that point if he sues then
almost certainly the union would seek a
temporary restraining order to stay the
suspension
and i think he'd probably get it
and if a court stays the suspension well
then deshawn watson is playing week one
against the carolina panthers so
you know i think the easy route out here
for the league is dependent on sue
robinson because the other two options
are taking ownership of the decision and
i think with one option it's is it
enough with the other option that you're
going to war again what do you think
happened
you know
for a while i've thought that they were
preparing to leave this alone and i
still believe that like i think that
they've set it up in a way and i've said
this to you like they've set it up in a
way where they can leave it alone
because they already got word out there
and you and i talked about it i think a
few weeks ago where
like
the judge was clearly upset that so much
of this became public right
well why would the league which is so pr
savvy risk angering a former district
court judge yeah
like why would they do that well they
would do that because they felt like the
thing may not be going their way
and if
she makes a decision they don't like
then they would have the recourse to say
we tried and so i think the easy route
out now is to pin this on robinson and
say this was her decision this is a new
process we negotiated this with the
union the owners don't want us involved
in every piece of this anymore
we're going to respect the process that
we set up two years ago with the union
to me that's like the cleanest exit and
i don't think it's
a value judgment on what happened with
lawson i think it's just
sort of protecting themselves going
forward the other two i think you'd be
would be more of a moral play
and i think the question is like
do they have the appetite to spend a
year in court with another star player
and make so many facets of the nfl
season
about desean watson because i think you
and i both know you remember the year
brady was in court the whole year
like that would not go away like he'd
probably be playing week one he'd
probably play the whole season because
the court process takes a while
and it would be a talking point
throughout the nfl season
in a month from now nobody's going to
remember this judge's name this is going
to be on roger goodell
whatever happens he either did or he
didn't
you know try to you know drop the hammer
onto sean watson and and trying to
you know they are
pr savvy but i wonder if you go hey we
tried
but we have to respect the process here
now we have to move to change what you
know the penalties are because all she
did if you read the 15 pages which i
know you did
she just used the history
recent history of punishments here you
bring up zeke elliott or you bring up
ben roethlisberger
she said yeah the nfl made your k you
made your case
but you know
that's this is what i'm gonna give i
can't she can't change the policy the
punishments that you've given i don't
think that's what i was surprised that
the nfl thought
she's going to do something on her own
which that's not part of her job i don't
think it was just hey you asked me to
look at this i'm looking at this this is
what i'm recommending that's it
judges operate on precedent you know and
judges
like her charge in this whole thing
is to make a decision that will allow
her
to write a brief that is appeal proof
like the judge the goal of any judge in
a situation like this
is to do something that's very fair and
down the middle
and
like takes into account everything
that's put in front of them and nothing
else right
and then in the end
be able to put something on paper that
is going to be very very hard to
challenge and if you read the opinion
like if you go into it it's really
interesting some of the things that are
in there like
you can see her playing both sides of it
right like like
one of the one of the most glaring
things to me was they both found she
both found him responsible for sexual
assault
and also called it non-violent like to
me like that was maybe the most
interesting thing and then she came up
with her own definition of sexual
assault which is unwanted
sexual contact contact
well is that by definition violent so
like there's there are a lot of things
in there where it's like you can see how
she's
sort of serving both sides
and
i i
this is just me reading it dan
it's really hard if you look at it to
challenge your process and that's that
that's the one thing everybody everybody
here has to remember right is if the nfl
appeals this and appeals it to goodell
or his designee
they can't they can't change the facts
the facts are the facts now right like
so you can't go and find
eight more women to talk to and and and
change the facts of this case are the
facts of this case
and so
like what you'd be doing is you'd be
challenging the process that sue
robinson went through and if you read
that brief
it's actually pretty hard to challenge
the process she took to get to the
decision that she made he's albert breer
senior nfl reporter he's the monday
morning quarterback
was there a deal in place for desean
watson at least offered a deal
yeah there was no deal in place but yeah
there were deals offered so there were
two sets of settlement talks essentially
one before the hearing another after the
hearing
the first set of of settlement talks
went absolutely nowhere the nfl was
insistent on at least a year
and they said if we don't get a year
we're going to seek an indefinite
suspension in the hearing
watson's camp wasn't going to go for a
year that was that like was just no
getting past that
i think when
like the interesting part of this that
never got out and i think this is
fascinating she actually told the
parties
in the hearing
to expect
a ruling the first week of august so
like as all of us were like where's the
ruling where's the ruling like the
people involved actually knew
that it was coming when it came and she
delivered it when on august 1st so like
the timing of it was exactly what she
said it was going to be
the people who were involved think she
gave them that month
to try to settle it on their own which
is common with judges right like give
the parties time to figure it out on
their own
they did get back to the table that was
the second set of settlement talks my
understanding is the league offered a
deal that would have been 12 games so it
would have brought him back for the last
five games of the season and a fine of
close to 10 million dollars which is
what he made last year so if you think
about that that would actually allow the
league then to say well last year that
actually that was a suspension so
because he got docked all his pay from
last year and so that would have allowed
the league if you think about this from
a pr standpoint to say we got pretty
close to what mlb did to trevor bauer
because he's been off the field for a
season and then three quarters of
another season
and he lost all of that money
so that was their offer and my
understanding is watson's camp was
willing to go to about six to eight
games
but not beyond that and so um that's
sort of where the divide was at the very
end before
they let robinson go ahead and make a
ruling here
yeah boy that's rolling the dice but it
worked out because you know uh
training camps you've been uh in green
bay uh thank bills brown steelers bears
colts let me start in green bay how's
morale with aaron rodgers this year
it's so calm there you know like i
remember going there last year i was
there day one um last year and it was
just everything was hitting the fan you
know what i mean like and um i actually
sat down and talked with him for about
25 minutes yesterday and um
he just seems very at peace with
everything you know like he just this is
it's almost this is where i'm going to
spend the rest of my career and he it
feels like he has ownership of the
offense he has some level of ownership
of the roster he's in lockstep like i
talked with brian gudukunst about how
they fixed their relationship last year
um
he seems like he's in a really good
place it was interesting because i asked
him about what the last year was like
and you know some of what we went
through was the criticism he took you
know over obviously
the the vaccine issue
and he said like it sort of taught him
to
try to stop paying attention to
everything on the outside like i guess
people like me and you you know what i
mean like and just focus on the people
who are around him as allies the people
in the locker room and it's just sort of
simplified his life which i thought
i no matter what you think about what
happened with him or whatever else like
i i actually look at it and it's he was
pretty
like i i think it put him and
ultimately want to putting him in a
pretty decent place here's the other
thing with devonte adams gone the other
thing i talked to him about
was how that team is now built sort of
the way the patriots used to build the
teams around tom brady where they didn't
over extend to put skill position
players around him but they're super
well-rounded dan that defense looks like
it's going to be electric i mean they
have seven first-round picks starting on
their defense
and like i think one thing that's
interesting about it is as aaron gets a
little bit older
now because they're really good
defensively they've got a really good
running game they're going to have to
they're going to be able to ask less of
him you know so he doesn't need to be
superman every week in fact he told me
like when i asked him about building the
roster he mentioned like the special
teams players he was like i'm really
excited about i'm not even kidding like
he's like
he was like i'm really excited about
these guys we have on special teams he's
like the last couple of years that's
cost us it was it was really really
interesting and it's
a very different tone than i've heard
from aaron in the past
you're in minnesota i'm fascinated what
was going on with mike zimmer and kirk
cousins that you have a coach who
i guess didn't like his quarterback i
don't know if the quarterback liked his
head coach
and yeah
so
what changed well you even had the gm of
the vikings saying hey we don't have tom
brady like what is what is kirk cousins
you know mentality going into this
season
well i mean i think it's going to be
like just like any quarterback his age
where to some degree you're like
fighting to extend your career i i do
think
like to me like what's happened in the
nfl at quarterbacks fascinating i think
you and i have talked about the home
sization of the nfl right like how
like good might not be good enough
anymore so the rams trade out your golf
to get matthew stafford the niners try
to level up by going jimmy garoppolo to
trey lance the browns go from baker
mayfield to deshaun watson
and
to me it's like
if you're gonna
look for that sort of opportunity
sometimes you have to be patient right
and so i think what the vikings and
raiders are doing is really interesting
because to me
it's sort of like what alex smith was in
kansas city where alex smith was a
really good quarterback who put you in a
position to compete in the here and now
establish a program and build a roster
and buy you time to wait for the right
opportunity so i think that's sort of
what minnesota is doing now with kirk
and i'm excited to get to talk to him
because he obviously has the
relationship with kevin o'connell from
washington and
they're going to run the offense that
you know he came up in and that he
played great in in washington and so
you know the way i look at he's got a
really good team around him he's got a
coach who likes him he's got a system
that he's thrived at in the past
and i mean yeah of course now because of
his age the junk junk service career
he's at
like he's fighting for his career
because like all for all that stuff i
just said about like buying yourselves
time you don't know when the right
opportunity is going to come along it
might be next year you know and then
he's gonna have to he may have to find
work somewhere else so i think he's just
in a really interesting juncture of his
career and like where i look at like
kirk cousins and um and derek carr now
is sort of in the same spot alex smith
once was with the chiefs did you see the
sideline video when they won a game last
second field goal
and kirk cousins pushes mike zimmer
mike zimmer pushes him back
and it looks like and then it looked
like mike zimmer wanted to go after him
yeah and then you find out that like it
didn't look like it didn't look like fun
and games no no it's like one of those
like hey we won boom and then he pushes
his quarterback and then i thought oh my
god like zimmer wanted it looked like he
wanted to fight kirk cousins after a win
yeah yeah
that thing went sideways and i i don't
know i'm not sure
you know zimmer always had his issues
with the
uh
with quarterbacks like zimmer and i love
zam like
i i
he has a little buddy ryan to him you
know what i mean like he always had a
little
buddy ryan like resenting the offense to
him and if you talk to the offensive
coaches they would tell you
like how they were restricted in certain
ways because there was a certain formula
he wanted to play
play with
and that would highlight his defense you
know and buddy ryan was always that way
rex ryan coached that way to some degree
so i think zimmer always had that sort
of old school like
a little natural resentment of
the offense and the quarterback
if it were to get in any way of his
defense performing at the level that he
thought it could
i know you weren't saying hey it's good
that i bring up buddy ryan because buddy
ryan actually punched some an offensive
uh an important offensive person like
kevin gilbrider yeah yeah uh before i
let you go anyways if that happened can
you imagine that happened now
and then uh sue robinson would have to
hear the case and then yeah
we would be getting a 15-page report on
it uh quickly the buffalo bills you went
to see them
what's if there's one issue everybody
loves buffalo
you got any issues with buffalo punter
i'm not even kidding like when i asked
them
it was my first stop um and um
like that team looks like it's loaded i
mean honestly even like you think about
like the running back situation right so
singletary and moss right
like they think james cook could be like
a poor man's version of his brother so
now you're putting him in the backfield
with a couple of other good players like
gabe davis is up to almost 230 pounds of
good weight like looks like he could be
a monster
um cair elam you know like looks like he
just not that he's making plays left and
right but just to sort of blend it in
with the first defense so
i
there's reason for
real optimism in buffalo i mean if josh
allen can pick up where he left off and
they really think like from a leadership
standpoint he hit a turning point at
like half time at the tampa game they
wind up losing that game but they came
back from way behind
um
if josh allen picks up where he left off
left off i mean
i don't think i'm speaking out of school
to say that could be like a 14 15 win
team
and you go back and look at josh allen's
rookie stats they're worse
than zach wilson
go back and look at honestly dan go back
and look at what everybody was saying
after that first year
about darnold about mayfield and about
alan
i mean like i think there are a lot of
people there were people who liked rosen
more than alan back then
after his rookie year
so it's a like huge credit to josh allen
because we don't see that like normally
like
like after a year we're not that far off
you know what i mean
if you read some of the stuff after 18
the stuff people were saying about josh
allen i mean
like i don't know a cold cold takes
exposed guy probably have a field day
with it
uh safe travels always great to talk to
you thank you for your insights thanks
dan that's albert breer the monday
morning quarterback